Today's episode is brought to you by T-Mobile America's best unlimited Network
What's going on guys? Game of Thrones!
Season 7 is nigh and there's so many characters so many plot points
I forgot a lot of what happened last season
So that's why we do our public service: "The Idiot's Guide to Game of Thrones", and we've got an amazing
crew to break down the last season for us. In fact
They are the hosts of Screen Junkies show 'Watching Thrones'. First, I'd like to introduce, you know her from
SJ News and all over the place Roth Cornet. Hello
I'm excited to get our Thrones on. Oh, she was one of the previous hosts of Watching Thrones, and she's emerged back
Welcome back Michelle Boyd. Thank you very much for having me again. I have a raging Throaner right now
He's the head writer of Honest Trailers. You know him, you love him, Spencer Gilbert
I drink and I know things, Hal. So we're going to break this down
piece by piece to make sure that you guys are all caught up and ready for the premiere of season 7. Roth,
shall we venture to the North. So the season opens and after torturing us fans
letting us guess Jon Snow is dead, Jon Snow is dead,
finally as predicted Melisandre brings him back to life at the behest of Ser Davos. "You were dead,
and now you're not. It's completely
*beep* mad." So maybe he's basically bulletproof for the rest of the series? He uses this opportunity to basically get out of his oath. "My watch has ended."
So yeah, we learned a little bit more about Melisandre. She went from Red Fox to Silver Fox! *laughs*
Or not quite a Silver Fox. She was yeah, just a hag. Like a hundred and ninety years old!
I do think that she will come back because I do think she has a larger role to play and she's still a big believer
in Jon Snow. "If you return to the North, I'll have you hanged as a murderer." There was a nice
Brother-Sister/Bastard-Sister reunion.
Since the first episode you're waiting for the Starks to get back together and who is it? It's Sansa and Jon who actually
didn't have that close of a relationship, but because of everything that they've been through
it's kind of 'trench mentality' and now they're very close. Except that she's not fully trusting Jon
She has an alliance with Littlefinger that she doesn't tell him about. Meanwhile Littlefinger is trying to convince her that
He and she together should take the Iron Throne. "...and you by my side."
So fan-favorite Lyanna Mormont comes out of nowhere to steal our hearts and make us want to elect her as president of the world
And she's ultimately able to get everyone rallying behind Jon. "He's my king from this day until his last day."
"The King in the North!"
And they're sort of like a sideways glance
and you're wondering is Littlefinger going to be able to convince her to go to the darkside fully. Now Ramsay has
Rickon. Of course Jon being Jon tried to save Rickon, which he cannot do.
*Gasps*
Jon Snow in one of the most amazing sequences of the season - you're right in the middle of it
Claustrophobic. So it's this amazing battle sequence,
and it looks like all is lost and lo and behold
the Knights of the Vale come to save the day in his big battle against Ramsay. "You suggested one-on-one
combat, didn't you? I've reconsidered."
He's going after Ramsay at Winterfell. Taking his home back. Taking his life back, and he just bleeds him to a bloody fricking pulp.
Oh yeah. So Sansa turns his own hounds on him. You realize she's had one of the best arcs on the show. *Barks*
Moving on to Michelle. Would you please take us beyond the wall. Poor freakin Meera has just been dragging Bran around for
seasons at this point, but we finally learned what Hodor's name means.
"Hold the door!"
*Echos* "Hold the door!"
Frickin Bran! So it's his fault.
Basically he was possessing Hodor to hold the door against the Undead Army in order to let him get away
Hold the door! Hold the door!
Talk to us about the Three-eyed Raven. He basically tells Bran, "the time has come for you to become me."
He dies. He lets Bran kind of take over the Green Seer and
gives him this new quest to go back
I'm the Three-eyed Raven now.
Green Seer basically just is kind of communing with Nature sort of thing. He taps into it with trees
He is able to tap into the history of Westeros
He basically is able to time travel and use the trees as sort of a Delorean. Woah!
I mean essentially. Bran goes back to a very key moment and Bran just learned that Lyanna made Ned promise to protect Jon
Lyanna is actually the mother and
probably Rhaegar Targaryen is the father. And he can influence events in the past. "Father!"
One more thing is that Benjen Stark came back in a big way
Coldhands appeared and for book nerds we were looking forward to the appearance of this character
And he helped his nephew Bran and Meera to escape. And then of course he was stuck behind the wall
But the question becomes for how long? Does Benjin come beyond the wall with the rest of the White Walkers? "I'll do what I can."
"As long as I can."
Spencer, um, let's go to your favorite spot on the map King's Landing. Oh, it's such a lovely cesspool!
To really understand King's Landing this season you have to know that as always
It's all about who controls the throne. Which at the beginning of season six, held by little bowl-cutted, kitten cuddling Tommen Baratheon
*Laughs* Aww! Yup!
And there's three very powerful factions vying for control of him. One is the Tyrells. They have their daughter
Margaery, married to Tommen so she's the Queen. Now team two is as always Cersei. She's got her claws into her kid
She's lost two out of three children already. She's got a seven-foot-tall zombie bodyguard
*Crunch*
And then finally we have this newly empowered branch of the High Sparrow and
religion has started to play a big part in King's Landing. "It's what the Gods wanted."
Cersei has got a trial date coming up for incest
You've got Margaery and Loras
imprisoned and this causes the other two
former rivals the Tyrells and the Lannisters to join together to put aside their differences and to take out the High Sparrow
But Tommen comes out and stops the ruckus from really happening. "The Crown and the Faith, together we will restore the Seven Kingdoms
to glory." Oh no, Cersei's defeated. Or is she?
Kaboom! She had wildfire planted under the Great Sept of Baelor, blew it all up. Everybody dead. So long!
Tommen, sweet little child that he is, was so distraught. He took a long jump off a high tower and never to be seen again
Cersei is down
three kids, up a glass of wine and up the Iron Throne which is what she may wanted all along.
I now proclaim Cersei of the House Lannister
Protector of the Seven Kingdoms.
Who arrives back in King's Landing at that very moment? Jaime did show up at the end of this season
He kind of went on a detour before that to break the siege of Riverrun. So he's really going through
this kind of identity crisis of what his role is. Is he a knight?
Who's he hold his loyalty to? He's still obsessed with Cersei, as he confesses, but then you also have big Brienne of Tarth,
holding him to a more chivalrous standard. "It's yours."
"It'll always be yours." Talk to us about Qyburn and
FrankenMountain. Qyburn, so he's an ex-Maester gone bad, pumping the Mountain
last seen dead in Trial by Combat
full of evil juice to make him into an unstoppable killing machine. Yes. You get to see a lot of that in season six
and it's awesome. Varys had his Little Birds, but the Little Birds are still present. Little Birds has been interesting
it's a term that Varys used throughout the series and it's a network of spies
made up of little children who will stab you if you cross them
So Margaery Tyrell is gone, but Lady Olenna is still around. Well, she ends the season lining up with Dorne
And what is my heart's desire?
Fire and blood
Michelle will you take us to Essos? At the beginning of the season you see Dani being kidnapped by a khalasar to get brought to
Vaes Dothrak. When Drogo was killed, Dani was supposed to go there and join the Dosh Khaleen
which is just basically the group of widows. So she gets brought over to Vaes Dothrak and
she says I'm not having any of this and burns them all. "Yeri vadrivoe."
Tyrion is there with her, they finally got together.
She made him Hand of the Queen. "I'd swear you my sword, but I don't actually own a sword."
After kicking out Daario to the curb saying yeah, you're cute
you're great in bed, but I'm gonna need to find me a husband.
"I can't bring another to Westeros." Theon and Yara came from Pyke. They
technically are royalty however
the Ironborn choose their next king and Theon and Yara's uncle Euron comes back after killing, Theon and Yara's father
"Aaargh!"
to take the throne by basically saying I'm going to let you all rape and murder and pillage as much as you want,
elect me King!
*Cheers*
He eventually wants to get over to Dany and make some kind of alliance with her. Theon and Yara get to Dany first and
make the alliance with her giving her all of the ships that they stole from the Ironborn. "Won't be enough to save them." Dany is finally
going to Westeros after six fricken seasons. Right?! She's going Westeros! She has an Unsullied army
She has ships from Yara, and Theon she's finally going with three full-blown dragons
*Roars*
Arya is also on her way home from Essos. She was the Girl With No Name
she was the blind little girl with no name who just keeps getting beaten up
Ugh!
Until she finally has a showdown with the Waif, she becomes no-one and Jaqen H'ghar says cool
you're one of us and she says no, peace, I'm going home. I'm Arya Stark mother*beep*er! Yeah!
The List still does mean something to her because in the last episode she goes after Walder Frey
"The last thing you're ever going to see is a Stark smiling down at you as you die."
Let's move on to a little speed round Jorah is, uh, he needs to visit the
dermatologist. Jorah has the same thing that
Stannis's daughter had. He has greyscale. The last thing that happens to Jorah is he does get exiled by Dany again
Saying "I command on you to heal yourself. Find the cure." Spencer, back on you, talk to us about those lovebirds Sam and Gilly
They're still together. They got a baby. He stole his dad's sword. He's studying at college. And that's the Citadel right?
Excellent. Roth, catch us up on the Hound. The Hound, who's a character that we love, that we thought was dead
He comes back, but it's very quickly, he meets up with this guy, Brother Ray who is Ian McShane
which is amazing, and this rogue group of
Brothers Without Banners coming in and they kill everyone that the Hound has connected with
taking away his reason to be a better man. So now
he's out for blood. He goes and he finds the Brothers Without Banners to get his revenge
But they're already gonna kill the rogues. The Brotherhood Without Banners is now headed to The Wall
It's possible that they'll connect with Melisandre on the way. And Beric Dondarrion,
who's been a part of the thing since season one is back, boom! And he's going to play a big role and we'll talk about that
more on our show. Ooh!
"Cold winds are rising in the North. We could use you."
Wow, you guys have done the yeoman's work you've taken us on a tour of season six now
I want to talk about, real quick, this new segment you have you're introducing to Watching Thrones called Raging Throaners. First off,
what exactly is a Raging Throaner? It's just the thing that gets us the most
excited about that episode or in this case the entire season. Would each of you give us your Raging Throaner from
season six. It was the explosion of the Sept. That whole sequence, that opening sequence to the finale was so
beautifully done, so talked about, and that's it. Erm, my favorite moment, Arya slitting Walder Frey's throat
It's been a culmination of everything
since her brother and her mother died, since her father died, since the List started
Finally she gets to cross the big one off her list
I'll say Jon Snow and the Battle of the Bastards. That one moment where he runs out and wants to take on
the entire army, solo. Come at me Boltons, I'm right here! Beautiful. What a great moment.
You know what those are all great Raging Throaners. I can't pick one better than the next. What's your Raging Throaner?
What's something that we left out or what's something that you're looking forward to in season seven of Game of Thrones?
Let us know in the comments section below, we want to know. I want to thank you guys for coming in and
dropping so much knowledge on us. Watching Thrones, when can we watch Watching Thrones? Every Monday! Screen Junkies News
11:00 a.m.
PST, live. Man that is going to be awesome. By the way everybody next week we're traveling down to San Diego
So make sure you check out Screen Junkies and Screen Junkies News on YouTube for all of our Comic-Con coverage presented by T-Mobile
America's best unlimited Network. I want to thank you for watching Screen Junkies. I'm Hal Rudnick. Hit me up on Twitter. Bye bye.